Das verschlägt selbst den Fachleuten die
Sprache.
Denn die Galaxie, die jetzt entdeckt wurde,
enthält keine oder nur sehr wenig Dunkle
Materie.
Und das ist wirklich äußerst mysteriös,
denn bislang gehen Fachleute davon aus, dass
sich Galaxien aus Dunkler Materie entwickeln.
Die aktuelle Entdeckung bestätigt somit nicht
nur eine ähnliche Messung aus dem vergangenen
Jahr, sondern stellt auch viele bisherige
Annahmen der Astronomie auf den Kopf!
Brauchen wir jetzt eine neue Theorie der Dunklen
Materie?
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts. herzlich willkommen!
Es ist jetzt das zweite Mal, dass ein Astronomen-Team
eine Galaxie aufgespürt, die keine oder nur
sehr wenig Dunkle Materie enthält.
Schon 2018 gab es eine riesige Aufregung um
die damals untersuchte Galaxie “NGC- 1052-DF2”.
Denn schnell stand fest, dass etwas nicht
mit ihr stimmte.
Das Forschungsteam entdeckte nämlich, dass
die Galaxie nicht nur fast durchsichtig, sondern
vor allem auch fast ohne Dunkle Materie existiert.
“Ein komplettes Rätsel (...), alles an
ihr ist merkwürdig”, hieß es von den beteiligten
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftlern.
Denn nach den bisherigen Annahmen dürften
Galaxien eigentlich gar nicht ohne Dunkle
Materie entstehen.
Und so wurde die Studie aus 2018 bis jetzt
mit großer Skepsis beäugt.
Auch, wenn die Dunkle Materie selbst für
uns immer noch ein großes Rätsel ist, glauben
wir zu wissen, dass sie der der wohl häufigste
Stoff im Universum ist.
Woraus Dunkle Materie genau besteht, ist aber
bis heute unklar und Forschungsteams weltweit
suchen mit Hochdruck nach einer möglichen
Erklärung.
Doch das ist einfacher gesagt als getan.
Denn die mysteriöse Dunkle Materie sendet
weder Licht aus noch verschluckt sie welches.
Ihr Nachweis gestaltet sich aufgrund dessen
als äußerst kompliziert.
Und so musste sich auch das Forschungsteam
aus den USA eines Tricks bedienen, um die
aktuelle Entdeckung überhaupt erst möglich
zu machen.
Dafür nutzten sie die Tatsache, dass Sternhaufen
in Galaxien umso schneller unterwegs sind,
je mehr Dunkle Materie die jeweilige Galaxie
besitzt.
Denn mit ihrer Schwerkraft verändert Dunkle
Materie eben beispielsweise die Bewegung der
Sternhaufen in Galaxien.
Und so nutzten die amerikanischen Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler das “Keck”-Teleskop
auf Hawaii, um insgesamt sieben Kugelsternhaufen
in der Galaxie “DF4” zu beobachten.
Genauso wie die im Jahr 2018 beobachtete Galaxie
befindet sie sich etwa 63 Millionen Lichtjahre
von der Erde entfernt.
Auch, wenn beide Galaxien von der Größe
her mit der Milchstraße zu vergleichen sind,
kann man sie nur schwer sehen.
Der Grund dafür ist, dass beide Objekte etwa
100 bis 1000 Mal weniger Sterne als die Milchstraße
enthalten.
Und das Ergebnis belegt, dass die Messung
aus dem letzten Jahr wohl korrekt war.
Denn auch in dieser zweiten Galaxie bewegen
sich die Sternhaufen viel langsamer als sie
es eigentlich tun müssten, wenn Dunkle Materie
vorhanden wäre.
Die Schlussfolgerung des Forschungsteam ist
eindeutig.
Die beobachtete Galaxie kann entweder nur
sehr wenig oder gar keine Dunkle Materie enthalten.
Und diese Entdeckung macht die beteiligten
Experten und Expertinnen zum zweiten Mal sprachlos.
Dazu der Astronom Pieter van Dokkum von der
Yale University: “Eine zweite Galaxie mit
keiner oder nur sehr wenig Dunkler Materie
zu finden, war genauso aufregend wie beim
ersten Mal.
Solange es nur ein Objekt gibt, hat man immer
diese leise Stimme im Hinterkopf, die sagt:
'Was, wenn du Dich irrst'?"
Laut der aktuellen Studie legt dieses Ergebnis
jetzt aber nahe, dass es wohl mehr Galaxien
ohne Dunkle Materie gibt als bislang angenommen.
Doch wie diese entstanden sind - das bleibt
weiter unklar.
Muss etwa eine alternative Theorie über Dunkle
Materie herangezogen werden, um dieses Rätsel
endlich lösen zu können?
Die beteiligten Fachleute sind diesbezüglich
skeptisch.
Der Wissenschaftler Pieter van Dokkum kann
sich vorstellen, dass die Dunkle Materie den
Galaxien mit der Zeit verloren gegangen ist.
Eine weitere Erklärung könnte sein, dass
sie aus Gas entstanden sind, das eine Nachbar-Galaxie
ausgestoßen hat.
Bei all diesen großen Fragezeichen liefert
die aktuelle Entdeckung dennoch eine wichtige
Erkenntnis: Nämlich, dass normale Materie
und Dunkle Materie unabhängig voneinander
entstanden sind.
Wow!
Dunkle Materie bleibt rätselhaft.
Draufklicken und anschauen und abonniert habt
hier Clixoom hoffentlich schon ansonsten:
Bis dann, bleibt dran!